you're walking down with
the younger version of you and sonny is
walking out with a younger version of
you
and
says so hey you know there's only three
things you do in jail what are they i
think it's you fight you
gamble you play i don't lift weights you
play cards you get in trouble and you
get in trouble yeah and he says what'd
you do he says i read and he says what'd
you read you said machiavelli yeah and
he says what's machiavelli he says
machiavelli was a somebody you know and
you give the history of 100 years ago
and then he said so what'd you learn you
said uh availability yes and he said
what do you mean availability he said i
can live anywhere why do i live here can
you unpack the concept of availability i
mean it was brief but i'm curious to
know about it
what happened was the wise guys
especially sunny he read machiavelli in
jail but not just him wise guys have
read sure it's it's mandatory it's
mandatory right
so
and when he explained it to me i was
like
i i and i i didn't read it back i read a
little bit back then but when i started
researching it when i was writing the
thing what i did was i took the
machiavelli principle and i made it into
a street language so what i did was
where he goes availability
let's say well this is actually right
from the play
i said availability goes yeah
availability he goes i can live anywhere
i want to live why do you think i live
here he goes availability
he goes
he goes he goes you see me he goes uh
i'm trying to take how he does he was
availability he goes because the people
that's he goes he goes a boss always has
to be available
what a freaking lie always he goes
because the people that see me here
every day that are on my side they feel
safe
they feel safe do you realize how
powerful this is and he's saying that
they feel safe because they know i love
them but the people that want to do
otherwise
they think twice
because they fear me so
you know the people that want to hurt
him that he when he's around there it's
different i mean
what i did was i took it next level and
i put it i put it into street terms
right and then in that scene correct me
if i'm wrong c asked back well is it
better to be loved there's a better fear
of the fear exactly and that's he asked
that question and this is a very big
topic on this movie right he goes is it
better to be loved or feared and he said
that's a good question he goes um
what he says to me goes he goes that's a
good question he goes
he goes in my world is better to be
feared right because trouble is like a
cancer when it's small like this it's
easy to cut out and get rid of but when
you're not around to see the trouble it
gets bigger and bigger and bigger and
then it eats the whole
you know and then you say the trick is
fearless not to be hated not because
that's right then he goes the trick is
not to be hated right he goes that's why
i treat my men well right not too well i
give them too much then they become
independent from yes i give them just
enough when they need me
but they don't hate me yeah awesome i
mean it's
i gotta tell you powerful time this is
the first movie the first movie in my
life back in the day with vhs my father
actually woke me up from sleep and said
come on you gotta come see this and he
dragged me out we just moved out of
brooklyn we were in jersey and he played
the scene about you know the working man
the worker man
a whole powerful scene with de niro but
also he swears to god to this day my
father was a brooklyn marine and a
garrison beach husky and he swears to
god from this day that that scene with
the bikers yes comes from the garrison
beach what they what they let me tell
you something we hear that when i hear
that i hear that
20 times a year
this came from 189th street uh this came
from queens yeah i know that story and i
go no it didn't no
maybe your thing happened there but no
this happened here i was sitting at the
bar this happened you know so everybody
says that yeah
everybody says that oh sonny in that
scene that pat references with the
machiavelli scene and everything like
that
prior to that like literally the minute
before that uh your dad robert nero
drops sonny uh drops c off on the bus he
sees you across the street and he sees
louie dumps across the street where's my
twenty dollars right and you say
well this is your friend do you like
this guy i know he says no isn't there
yeah exactly and he says forget the 20.
yeah and i'm like what he goes look look
at it this way because you twenty
dollars to get rid of get rid of him out
of your life he's never gonna bother you
again he's never gonna ask you for money
again he's out of your life for 20 hours
for you exactly he says you got off
cheap you gotta have cheap we were
talking about this last night about
having to pay for
situations where you know things could
get ugly and it's like
you know in this case 20 bucks you got
off cheap maybe 50 grand you get off
cheap right you know 100 grand the story
you told you could have got off chief
yeah what's the money lesson at that
it's just you cut your losses basically
you cut your losses and you know what
he's never he can't ask you for money
again ever
you got to be machiavelli on these guys
look i knew my friends i knew my friends
i was doing all this in hollywood it's a
funny story i'm doing all this in
hollywood right i knew my friends were
gonna ask me for money because it was
going to be in the newspapers it was
going when you got the memo when i got
the oh i got more than a million well
they all were they offering you money
when you had a broken radiator though
that's the other side of it so i called
i called my friends up before all this
hit big yeah and i went you know you
know i'm doing okay but i need listen to
me is it possible if you let me ten
grand get out of here now i knew they
was you know what
no way they could give me 10 grand they
were married guys you know yeah
the chads i can't i got kids i totally
understand that don't worry about it you
know i'm just a little desperate right
now call all five of them seven of them
up wow and they asked them for money
boom as soon as i got to check they
couldn't ask me for money of course
wow
wow
so what's that they called me up and i
said hey yeah congratulations i said hey
yeah we're all worked out i didn't need
the 10 grand
that's awesome
wow i won't i won't tell you who it is
but there's the only thing i've ever
heard that even remotely comes close to
that there's a guy i played ball sick
he had been divorced twice and was about
to get divorced for the third time so he
was a veteran okay
so he calls every single divorce divorce
lawyer
in the state
so that when he when he files for
divorce his wife at the time cannot get
a divorce lawyer oh because he's he's
already entered into conversations wow
so he literally took two days of his
life and called a thousand attorneys
veteran because this was his third time
i was like bro you really wanted out of
that man well he's an experienced
divorce
that's your third one you know none of
those guys could even they couldn't
attempt to ask you because they already
have one guy did but
you didn't give me the 10 grand i asked
you now you need to yeah i said no oh
you want money now but i assure you he
goes oh come on i could i said no i
can't do it man i couldn't afford it
chess that's awesome chess dude
i still can't get over the fact you're
in your 30s you're a struggling actor
man and you're out there your bottom
dollar somebody wants to buy a script
they want to option your script that
that in and of itself is a dream half a
million dollars no no yeah you
understand that that's like hitting on
20 right like like you're showing two
kings and you're hit this only happened
three times in the history of hollywood
happened three times it happened with
sly sloane rocky rocky happened with me
obviously bronx still and it happened
again with big fat greek wedding uh so
it happened three times that's it now
what that where the person wrote the
one-person show and actually was in it
and it was in the movie
three times that happened sure it
happened a few more times and it didn't
end up well though no it's not at this
level
at this level yeah at this level success
sure success so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]